cette séquence s'appelle construction
j'aime beaucoup celle-ci il y a Bing bong
comme guide touristique qui est en fait un
non-conformiste radical alors Bing bong nous avons fait une
version encore plus extrême de la joie en ce
qu'il est littéralement vous savez jeter des briques
et protester et être un  excitateur rebelle
pour que Riley reste comme elle était pour
son propre bénéfice qu'est-ce qu'ils font dans la
construction ils élargissent l'esprit de Riley
c'est le nouveau centre de recherche sur les garçons,
donc Riley n'a besoin de rien de tout cela,
pourquoi les choses ne peuvent-elles pas rester telles qu'elles
sont parce que des secousses comme celles-ci le regardent en
souriant et il ne sourira pas quand la
révolution arrivera, vous entendez  moi nous n'allons pas
prendre ça couché
nous allons ramener le pouvoir
de la récréation aux gens imaginaires ce n'est pas du
progrès
[Musique]
hé non nous ne grandirons pas
en fuite de
toute façon  ay mis en quelque deux par six l'
initiative passe l'inspection